foreign  [Music]  that that to me is creepy that freaks me  i actually find i'm not even kidding i  find this deeply  on a real visceral level i find that  very disturbing that whole scene the  look on the dog's face was was a look of  saying help me he's pleading with the  camera  to the pleading with the public  come and rescue me from this serial  killer i'm living with listen man if  you're dating a woman and she has a  little dog like in fact if she has a  little dog at all that's a good reason  to run away but especially if she has a  literal bed with a nightstand and a lamp  that by the way the dog can't turn that  lamp on and off  then that's that's a good indication  that this woman will murder you in your  sleep